النجمه اللبنانيه ورد الخال بتطل على
الجمهور في الموسم الرمضاني بدور بطوله
ضمن مسلسل للممثلاثه ودورها هو دور كارما
سيده الاعمال صاحبه الشخصيه القويه زوجه
الام القائده لعصابه مافيا طويله عريضه
بتخوض فيها حرب مع اخوها واللي بيتابع
للموته راح يعرف انه ورد او كارما في هذا
الجزء محرك اساسي للاحداث ولعمل كل من سحر
اللي بتادي دورها طبعا النجمه ماجي بغصن
وريم واللي بتادي دورها النجمه دانيال
رحمه وللتذكير مسلسل الموت لوموسيمان
رمضانيين وقدر يجمع حوالينه كثير من
المحبين والمتابعين والمتشوقين لاحداثه
ويبدو انه الجزء الثالث حكايته مختلفه
والمواجهه راح تكون نسائيه وفي تونس
تحيات مثل البيانو
عقد ما تاخذي منها عقد ما بتعرفي تلعبي
انا رميت بعائله
حاسه حالي وحيده
علمتني انه شك بكل الناس اللي حوالي
انا محلك كمان بضلوعي
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا من بيروت النجمه ورد الخال
اهلا فيك معانا يا ورد منورتنا اليوم كل
عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
رمضان كريم منوره بوجودكم الله يخليكي
صراحه
تمام والسنه يعني لما شفنا اسمك وانضمامك
للعمل قلنا اوف يعني الموضوع رح يكبر بس
انت كورد الخال لما نجو قالوا لك تعالي
انضمي لنا في السيزون الثالث يعني عاده
الواحد بيخاف اذا ما كان موجود من البدايه
حسيت بهذا الخوف
[موسيقى]
لازم تكوني بهذا الجزء لانه
دور دور حلو
ولازم تعرف فاكيد تحمست انا وخاصه انه انا
شايله مع شركه ايجل فينيمز اعمال عديده
يعني
اخدت النص وقرايته وكثير تحملته كتير حبيت
شخصيه كارما هلا هي مكروهه بكل الوطن
العربي بصراحه يعني انا هذا الشيء حابه
يعني اقدر افهمه منك يعني ورد كيف عامله
شخصيه وحده هذا القد شريره وهذا القد
كريهه بس في نفس الوقت محافظه على هدوءك
وكلاس كيف كيف عملتيها
عملتيها عملناها هي مكتوبه على الورق
امراه عندها جبروت عندها قوه عندها سلطه
ولكن امراه يعني عندها بتوصل لاهدافها
بطرق ملتويه كونها هي شغله شغل شغل
من اللي بتشتغل بشكل قانوني طبعا هي هي
قائده
مافيا
والى اخره
حبيت انه اصورها بطريقه بعيده عنك مره
الشريره اللي بتبين لا هي امراه
تعزف بها نوم في كثير نماذج
بمجتمعاتنا بيكونوا مرتبين وحلوين
وانيقين بس
هنعمل تحت السواهد قولي لي هتقولي لي
نقدر نجلس نحط القهوه ونحكي على الموضوع
فتره ط
اكيد يعني هيك تصورتها يعني وشفتها وطبعا
مع الحديث مع الكيك بنادين جابر قالت له
هاي هي اللي انا هيك بتخيلها فقلت لها
عظيم طبعا مع المخرج الاسمر نحنا هالثلاثه
رسمنا شخصيتها شكلها ومضمونه البادي لانج
تبعها صوتها الى اخره انه امراه بتقدر
توصل للي بدها اياه وما في شي صعب عندها
ورايقه
شفناها هيك شفناها
ورد ولا في احد ثاني بيعزف
انا انا مش انا هدول مش اصابيع اوكي لانه
قلت كمان لو طلعت تعزف بيانو كمان يعني
بزياده كمان الموضوع طيب خليني
وحلو طبعا بس ورد يعني كمان صراحه لمن
اوكي ورد الخال باقي بغصن دانيلا رحمه
يقولوا دائما الستات ما يعرفوا يشتغلوا مع
بعض ولازم تصير بينهم مشاكل وافلام انتم
ما شاء الله ثلاثه اسامي قويه في عمل
بطوله نسائيه مطلقه يعني كيف مش الوضع
يعني شو بدي اقول لك احلى الاوقات متعه
فعلا احلى الاوقات اربعه اشهر ونص تقريبا
ليل نهار عم نشتغل بقلب بقلبه شو بقولوا
بعشق وبيشغف طبعا كانوا كمان كثير مرحبين
كانوا كانوا
حاضنينني بشكل كثير كبير وهن بشخ يعني كل
حدا منهم كان محمص لدوري بشكل كثير كبير
يعني يلا وماجي عشقانين دور كارما
الحماس موجود على
نضحك كثير بهالمشاهد هدول نحن اصحاب
اصدقاء في الف كثير اشتغلنا بقلب واحد
يعني
ولو ما هيك ما كان طلعت هيدي النتيجه مع
انه نحن اللي بيشوفنا مع بعض بشوفنا
بالشخصيات بقول هدول بيكرهوا بعض كثير
يعني بس بالحقيقه ما فيني اقول لك شو كان
الجو حلو وشو زعلنا انه خلص المسلسل خلص
هيدا الشغل يعني لا اكيد نحن بتواصل مستمر
بنحكي عن عن كواليس العمل وكل حدا منك جزء
رابع
نعم هل نتوقع جزء رابع
يمكن ما بعرف يعني هذا الشيء بيرجع للشركه
الانتاج وللقيمين وللمحطه ما بعرف الحقيقه
ما بعرف حب يكون فيه
انا مشاهد وكنتابعه للعمل اكيد بحب بس مش
بالضروره اكيد تكون بالجزء الرابع هو
يعني يمكن ينتهي دورك هذا الجزء
[موسيقى]
يعني
اوكي صح صح لانه الجزء الثالث
الجزء الثاني قفلنا انه ماتوا كانوا رجعوا
تاني تنقذوا فكل شيء ممكن يعني
[موسيقى]
بس مش يعني بعد هيدا بكير الحكي عليه
الحقيقه
اللي بعرفه انه دائما هم عندهم تحدي انه
يعملوا اشياء جديده ودائما هم بينتروا رد
فعل الجمهور وانتم كل الظروف يعني لحتى
يخوضوا هالتحدي مره ثانيه يعني بس انا
اكيد بتكون من المتابعين
يعني خلاص انا بحس صرت فرد من من هالعمل
هيدا من هالمشروع
ورد ما في
بس ما في صراحه بدي يعني ما بدي اعدي
الوقت بلا ما اسالك انه من اول حلقه واحنا
جالسين بنتابع ملابسك صراحه
وشكلك بشكل عام يعني ما شاء الله عليك كيف
محافظه على هذا الجسم ما شاء الله عليك
والملابس
بعمل رياده كتير
باكل كثير وبعمل رياضه كتير مع بعضهم
كم طولك يا ورده بس اكيد انا طول المتر
و75 ونص بس عم بلبس كعوبه كمان يعني عم
بلبس كعب عالي فشي ارهاقن الحقيقه
الطبيعيه
بكارما يعني فدائما حريصه ان دايما اطلع
بعيده كليا عن شخصيه الحقيقيه طبعا هيدا
هدفي وهذا التحدي لالي كتير اشخاص ورا
هاللوك اللي عم يلي لا اعجاب عند الناس
طبعا
في جنود
مجنولين بس هن ويكابونه مثل رولا سليمان
فريق يعني
طبعا ورده حاولت اني استفيد يعني من اللي
انت نصيحتك في هذا الموضوع لكن مش راح
تمشي معايا احتاج اسال احد ثاني اشوف احد
ثاني غيرك ههه طيب لكن شكرا لك متالقه
متالقه متالقه اعطيتي للموت كمان طعم
اضافي جديد شكرا لك كانت معنا من بيروت
النجمه ورد الخال
[موسيقى]